let's bring in Ariel Helwani MMA
fighting dot-com journalist a student of
the sport here Ariel joins us now thank
you I know you're busy so what do we
expect tomorrow night I'm expecting the
greatest sporting event of all time
we've been on this journey together yes
back in November I'm happy that we were
able to end it at the finish line
together all right what do you think how
does this actually play out
strategy-wise in the ring give me both
both fighters strategy well we know
what's what no secrets here
49 and now he's primarily remained the
same boxer actually in the last few
years very much a defensive fighter you
know he said recently that he's going to
come forward and he's like to pay the
fans back for the Manny Pacquiao debacle
I don't believe that's true I think he's
gonna be the same but the interesting
thing is Conor Conor I think is going to
surprise a lot of people a lot of people
think that Congress just gonna go out
there and try to outbox one mayweather
that would be a colossal mistake he's
going to go in there as a martial artist
he is going to try to reign a style of
the tag that Boyd has never seen before
I know it's very interesting at the
press conference two days ago when they
faced off in front of a crowd
Floyd stood there like a traditional
boxer Connor Den went down and said this
is Bruce Lee expletive and then the
Bruce Lee pose and that was his signal
to the world and I'm not going in there
as a boxer I'm going in there as martial
artist make this dirty I'm gonna bring a
very unorthodox style of attack the
Floyd Mayweather yeah I mentioned that
in the first hour that he's going in
obviously as a left-hander and Floyd has
seen left-handers but he's an
unconventional left-hander is that what
you're talking about that his approach
is going to be something different or is
it angles that he's playing that will be
different than a typical boxer the
approach will be different I think it
would be a very dirty fight you know
they put out a clip of this all right a
couple weeks ago and he's throwing
rabbit punches you know he's gonna he's
gonna throw punches to the elbows gonna
throw punches to the shoulder he's just
gonna try to rough him up Connors not a
very he's not volume plant sure he's a
very precise hunter a very hard hitter
and I think that's the game plan yeah I
mean just look around him he has no
boxing trainers in his corner his three
corner men are his MMA inners and
there's so he's not again he
not gonna try to go in there try to you
know slip and dip and an out box boy
because I think that he would get
outclassed and embarrassed if he did
that I think he's going to try to rough
them up and play dirty with it which
sport has more on the line 100% boxing
this is a boxing match could you imagine
if arguably the greatest fighter of all
time arguably the greatest defensive
fighter of all time
49 and Oh Floyd Mayweather loses to the
oh no martial artist I have to say it's
been really interesting to see how the
boxing community has accepted or I
really should say not accepted Conor
they have mocked him yeah
openly mocked him throughout this
process they are laughing at him there
they're putting up videos making fun of
his training could you imagine if he
goes in there and actually stops Floyd
something that none of these other
grades
Pacquiao's De La Hoya Canelo Robert
Gaara all these guys couldn't do
couldn't even touch Floyd couldn't knock
him down
I mean boxing would be they would be
facing a lot of questions if Connor is
able to do that give me the result that
keeps Conor McGregor in boxing and Dunn
returned to MMA honestly I think he
returns to MMA really heartless yes you
know why because I feel like the UFC
obviously had to be on board with this
idea he's still under contract with them
they're making a lot of money off this
fight as well and I don't believe that
they would have let him go out and do
this and pursue this if they didn't get
some kind of assurance mmm
that he would be coming back and I've
asked his management team about this and
they kind of wink-wink nudge-nudge but
but based on my conversations there is a
discussion that was said that was had a
few months back that he would come back
and he has said multiple times that he
plans by coming back and his coaches
said multiple times and I believe them I
believe that he is very much willing to
come back and obviously he'd have to get
paid a lot more but the plan at least as
of right now before this fight is for
him to come back at least one more time
this year inside the Octagon if I bet I
would be putting money on McGregor for a
knockout
but you know I don't bet any more but
people are looking at the different
angles here you got to put up a whole
lot of money for to get anything back on
Mayweather what would you do if you were
betting
honestly I'm not a better I've actually
never bet on anything in my life maybe
once or twice or like my friends but I
can't even recall the last time I made a
bed of any kind of significance I
actually feel like the safe bet is Floyd
because yeah I checked it was four to
one I mean this should be with all you
know I have all the respect in the world
for Conor and as I told you you know a
month or so ago I'm not gonna be the one
who says he doesn't have a chance
but Conor should be a twenty to one
underdog in this fight I mean O&O gets
forty nine I know it's crazy to me that
it's actually this close and I think
that speaks to just how popular he is
and how loyal his fanbase is but the
fact that it's so close I kind of feel
like the safer bet at this point it's
Floyd he's Ariel Helwani
MMA fighting dot-com journalist one of
the more respected voices certainly in
this sport can you when you talk to
Conor McGregor
recently if you know can you get just a
normal guy who's named Conor or or was
he on as Conor McGregor no I have to say
with me I feel like I've been lucky and
maybe it's because you know we first
crossed paths before he came to the UFC
he has always been very down-to-earth
very humble you know I mean his his
comments to me are at times you know
illuminating and mesmerizing and he's
just such an eloquent speaker and I just
love the way he sort of tackled certain
subjects I had the privilege of sitting
down with him two weeks ago after his
open media workout session and you'd
probably appreciate this because you
followed a bit of my journey over the
past year and a half UFC did not want
him to sit down with me he was only able
to sit down with Fox ESPN and Showtime
you know the big dogs if you will and
Here I am the little train that could
who's been along for the ride with Conor
for quite some time and they asked me to
leave the performance Institute they
call that their headquarters now and I
said no I'm going to wait to talk to
Connor and they went to speak to Connor
and said you know aerials you're waiting
for him he said absolutely I'll speak to
him and he gave me 25 minutes longer
than Jim Gray longer than all the
veterans who were there so with me he's
always been great and the interview was
was great because we talked about him
being on welfare and he has this new
yacht that he just purchased and he
calls it the 188 and that's because when
he was on welfare his check was 188
euros and you know so we kind of remand
about that we reminisce about being a
father now and what it's like doing this
with a son so it was it was Connor it
was up if you will how long did you have
to wait for the interview for Connor we
had to wait you know maybe an hour and a
half first okay that pales in comparison
to what I had to do to get Floyd a
couple days ago did you hear about this
story is this the six hours you waited
yes I waited six hours on Monday Floyd
Mayweather said that he was going to be
hanging out at his gentlemen's club
leading up to the flight every night and
quite frankly I didn't believe him I
know he likes to you know stay up late
and things like that but I thought that
maybe he'd stay away at least for this
week so I talked to my crew on Wednesday
and I said let's just go there and see
if he's actually telling the truth so we
went at 10:30 p.m. spoke to hit the
bouncers and all that you know they kind
of are a little bit hesitant when they
see people walk in with cameras they put
us in a room top of the club closed the
door behind us so it was a vault door
that was maybe like eight feet wide I
thought that they were gonna lock us in
there until after the fight one hour
passes two hours three hours four hours
five hours he finally shows up at 3:30
a.m. Pacific time
comes in there with a stack of money and
I'm like oh my god he's finally here so
and I'm half asleep at this point I was
wearing those solar eclipse glasses so I
didn't look at anything at the wall and
and and I go up to his bodyguard and I'm
like hey you know can we talk to them
finally he's here he's like he doesn't
want to do it he's not feeling it so I
said I can't I mean I've come this far
five hours I've been sitting in this
darn place so we go up to him I say
please I've been here six hours I've
waited an hour to speak to him and he
said all right fine let's do it we went
upstairs at 4 a.m. Pacific time went up
and got the interview with him it was
pretty darn cool I'm let's say you may
put up a better fight than Conor
McGregor will against there no I I don't
know maybe I'm too entrenched at this
point but I don't think it will be a
stinker just because Conor's never been
in a stinker and I know this is
unchartered territory but he's just not
that kind of fighter he's not the kind
of fighter who will just stand there and
not throw punches like Manny Pacquiao
did so he's either gonna you know go out
on his shield or he's gonna pull off
maybe the greatest upset of our lifetime
but I just would be absolutely shocked
that this is a thinker maybe I'm being
foolish maybe you know I'm being naive
but that's just my feeling at this point
they're real great to talk to you keep
fighting
good fight thank you my friend all the
best and my pleasure Ariel Helwani MMA
fighting calm the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience